TRYING TO SET IT UP AND IT IS
OUT TO THE CENTERENT TEAMS GOINT
IT DIFFERENTLY BUT THEY BOTH
HAVE THAT EXTRA THING THAT NOT A
LOT OF PART TO CLOSE IT OFF ASEO
THE FIRST ROUND.
YOU HAVE TO BRING IN.
>> HE WAS LOOKING FOR MACDERMID
THE WHOLE TIME.
>> YES, HE DEFTLY WAS.ENSIVE LIE
WHEN I PLAYED.
BUT WE ALWAYS HAD T T AVALANCHE.
>> THE FOR HIS
FIRST GOAL NEUTRALIZE.♪ AND IT G
ANGLE AND HE'S ABLE TO GET THE
PUCK INTO THE TOP PART OF
SCORING.
NATHAN TO EXPIRE,
GREENWAY IS OUT-OF-THE-BOX. GREY
LOOKING THE GLOVES SHIN
PAD.
THEY COULD NOT PICK IT UP, BUT
IT'S DEFINITELY A SET PLAY AND
THE SAVE.
THE PUCK
RIGHT ONTO HIS HAND.
HE DOES A GREAT JOB, IN MY
OPINION, A
BACKHANDER UP IN THE
MINNESOTA. ZUCCARELLO, HARTMAN,E
SCORES.
[CHEERS] IT IS FAST AS YOU
CAN.
EVERYONE ELSE IS ON TOP
OF THE POST AS
THE